I want to bring everything we've learned
about linear independence and dependence
and the the span of a set of factors
together in one particularly hairy
problem because if you understand what
this problem is all about I think you
understand what we're doing which is key
to your understanding of linear algebra
these two concepts so the first question
I'm going to ask about the set of
vectors s and they're all three there
are all three-dimensional vectors they
have three components is does is the
span of s is the span of S is that equal
to r3
and it seems like it might be if each of
these add new information it seems like
maybe I could describe any vector in r3
by these three vectors by some
combination of these three vectors and
the second question I'm going to ask is
are they linearly linearly independent
independent and maybe I'll be able to
answer them at the same time so let's
answer the first one can they span do
they span r3 and two span r3 that means
some linear combination of these three
vectors should be able to construct any
vector in r3 so let me give you a linear
combination of these vectors so I could
have c1 times the vector first vector 1
minus 1 2 plus some other arbitrary
constant c2 some scalar times the second
vector 2 1 3 plus some third scaling
factor times the third vector minus 1 0
2 now I should be able to using some
arbitrary constants take a combination
of these vectors that sum up to any
vector in r3 and I'm going to represent
any vector in r3 by the vector a B and C
where a B and C are any real numbers so
this if I can if you give me any a B and
C and I can give you a formula for
telling you what your C 3s your C 2's
and your C ones are then that
essentially means that it spans r3
because if you give me a vector I can
always tell you how to construct that
vector with these three so let's see if
I can do that
so just from our definition of
of scalar multiplication of a vector we
know that c1 times this vector I could
rewrite it if I want to I normally skip
the step but I really want to make it
clear so c1 times this I could just
rewrite it as 1 times C it's each of the
terms times C 1 similarly c2 times this
is the same thing as each of the terms
times C 2 and C 3 times this is the same
thing as each of the terms times C 3 I
want to show you that everything we do
it just formally comes from our
definition a vector of multiplication of
a vector times a scalar which is what we
just did or vector addition which is
what we're about to do so a vector
addition tells us that this term Plus
this term Plus this term needs to equal
that term so let me write that down we
get C 1 plus 2 C 2 minus C 3 will be
equal to a likewise we can do the same
thing with the next row minus C 1 plus C
2 plus 0 C 3 must be equal to B so we
get minus C 1 minus C 1 plus C 2 plus 0
C 3 so we only have to write that is
going to be equal to B and then finally
let's just do that last Row 2 c1 2 c1
plus 3 c2 plus 3 c2 plus 2 C 3 plus 2 C
3 is going to be equal to C right there
now let's see if we can solve for our
our different constants so I'm going to
do it by elimination I think you might
be familiar with this process I think
I've done it in some of the earlier
linear algebra videos before I started
doing a formal presentation of it and
I'm going to review it again when we in
a few videos from now but I think you
understand how to solve it this way what
I'm going to do is I'm going to first
eliminate these two terms and then I'm
going to eliminate this term and then I
can solve for my various constants so if
I want to eliminate this term right here
what I could do is I could add this
equation to that equation or even better
I can replace this equation with the sum
of these two equations so let me do that
so I'm just going to I'm just going to
add
these two equations to each other and
replace this one with that sum so minus
C 1 plus C 1 that just gives you 0 I can
ignore it then C 2 plus 2 C 2 that's 3 C
2 3 C 2 and then 0 minus 0 plus minus C
3 is equal to minus C 3 minus C 3 is
equal to and I just added I'm replacing
this with the sum of these two so B plus
a equals B plus a let me write down that
first equation on the top so the first
equation I'm not doing anything to it so
I get C 1 plus 2 C 2 minus C 3 is equal
to a now in this last equation I want to
eliminate this term so let's let's take
this equation and subtract from it 2
times this top equation so 2 times so
minus 2 times them so you could also
view it as let's add this 2 minus 2
times this top equation and since we're
almost done using this when we actually
you're going to wrote it let's just
multiply this times minus 2 so this
becomes a minus 2 C 1 minus 4 C 2 plus 2
C 3 so plus 2 plus 2 C 3 is equal to
minus 2 a right if you just multiply
each of these terms I would be very
careful I don't wanna make a careless
mistakes minus 2 times C 1 minus 4 plus
2 and then minus 2 and now we can add
these two together and what do we get
the 2 C 1 minus 2 won't see one that's a
0 don't have to write it 3 C 2 minus 4 C
2 that's a minus C 2 minus C 2 and then
you have your 2 C 3 plus another C 2 C 3
so that is equal to plus 4 C 3 is equal
to C minus 2 a C minus 2 a all I did is
I replace this with this minus 2 times
that and I got this now I want to
eliminate
now I'm going to keep my top equation
constant again I'm not going to do
anything to it so I'm just going to move
it to the right so I get C 1 plus 2 C 2
minus C 3 is equal to a and I'm also
going to keep my second equation the
same so I get 3 C 2 minus C 3 is equal
to B plus a let me scroll over a good
bit and then this last equation I want
to eliminate my goal is to eliminate
this term right here so what I want to
do is I want to multiply this bottom
equation times 3 and add it to this
middle equation to eliminate this term
right here
so if I multiply this bottom equation
times 3 let me just do well actually let
me I don't want to make things Messier
so this becomes a minus 3 plus a 3 so
that goes cancel out this becomes a 12
minus a 1 right so that becomes so this
becomes 12 C 3 minus C 3 which is 1111 C
3 and then this becomes a this becomes a
oh sorry I was already done
I want after when I do 3 times this Plus
that those cancelled out and then when I
multiply 3 times this I get 12 C 3 minus
a C 3 so that's 11 C 3 11 C 3 and I
multiply this times 3 plus this so I get
3 C minus minus 6a minus 6a right I'm
just multiplying this times 3 plus this
plus B plus B plus a and so what can I
give rewrite this by and actually I want
to make something very clear this C is
different than these C 1 C 2 s and C 3s
that I had up here I think you realize
that but I just realized that I use the
letter C twice and I just didn't want
any confusion here so this C that
doesn't have any subscript is a
different constant than all of these
things over here so let's see if we can
simplify this so we have an A and a
minus 6a so let's just add them
let's go to that a and then this becomes
minus five a so we get and then if we
divide both sides of this equation by
eleven what do we get we get we get C 3
C 3 is equal to 1 over 11 1 over 11
times 3 C minus 5 a so you give me any a
or C and I already tell you what C 3 is
now what is C 2 C 2 is equal to let me
simplify this equation right here let me
do it right there so if I just add C 3
to both sides of equation I get 3 C 2 is
equal to B plus a plus C 3 well I know
and then if I divide both sides of this
by 3 I get C 2 C 2 is equal to 1 over 3
times B plus a plus C 3 I'll just leave
it like that for now and then what is C
1 is equal to well if I I could just
rewrite this top equation as if I
subtract 2 C 2 and add C 3 to both sides
I get C 1 is equal to a a minus 2 C 2
plus C 3 so what have I just shown you
you can give me you can give me any
vector in r3 that you want to find so
you can give me any real number for a
any real number for be any real number
for C and if you give me those numbers
I'm claiming now that I can always tell
you some combination of these three
vectors that will add up to those and
I've actually already solved for what I
have to multiply each of those vectors
by to add up to this third vector so you
give me what your a is B and C's I just
have to substitute into the the A's and
the C's right here and oh sorry I forgot
this B over here there was also a B it
was suspicious that I didn't have to
deal with the B so this is a there was a
B right there so this is 3 C minus 5 a
plus B let me write that
be there's a bee right there in a
parenthesis but I think you get the
general idea
you give me your a B's and C's any real
numbers can apply I'm not dividing by
there's no division over here so I don't
have to worry about dividing by zero so
this is just a linear combination of any
real numbers so I can clearly get
another real number so you give me your
a B's and C's I'm going to give you a C
3 now you give me a BS and CS I got a C
3 this is just going to be another real
number and I'm just going to take that
with your up form or A's and B's and I'm
going to be able to give you C 2 and
then I already give you we already be
able to solve for C 2 and a C 3 and then
you I just use your a as well and then
I'm going to give you a C 1 so hopefully
you're seeing that no matter what a B
and C you give me I can give you a C 1 C
2 or C 3 there's no reason that any a
B's recieves should break down these
formulas we're not doing any division so
it's not like a zero would break it down
so I can say definitively that the set
of vectors of these three vectors does
indeed span r3 now let me ask you
another question where I already asked
it are these vectors linearly
independent
are they lis linearly independent now we
said that in order for them to be
linearly independent the only solution
the only solution to you know C 1 times
my first vector 1 minus 1 2 plus C 2
times my second vector 2 1 3 plus C 3
times my third vector minus 1 0 2 so if
something is linearly independent that
means that the only solution to this
equation EECOM nth there's the only
solution to this equation so if I want
to find some set of combinations of
these vectors that add up to the zero
vector and I did that in the previous
video if they are if they are linearly
dependent there must be some nonzero
solution so one of these constants at
least one of these constants would be
nonzero for this solution I mean you can
always make them zero no matter what but
if they're linearly D
pendant then one of these could be
nonzero if they're linearly independent
if they're linearly independent then all
of these have to be the only solution to
this equation would be C 1 C 2 C 3 all
have to be equal to 0 C 1 C 2 C 3 all
have to be equal to 0 linear
independence implies this this implies
linear independence now this is the
exact same thing we did here but in this
case what I'm just picking my a B's and
C's to be 0 this is a this is B and this
is C and this is C right I can pick any
vector in r3 for my HB and Z's I'm now
picking the 0 vector so let's see what
our C 1 C 2 s and C 3 s are so by a
equals B is equal to C is equal to 0 I'm
setting it equal to the 0 vector what
linear combination of these three
vectors equal the zero vector
well if a B and C are all equal to 0
that term is 0 that is 0 that is 0 you
have 111 times zero times 0 minus 0 plus
0 that's just 0 so C 3 is equal to 0 now
C 3 is equal to 0 we already know that a
is equal to 0 and B is equal to 0 C 2 is
1/3 times 0 so it equals 0 now what's C
1 well it's C 3 which is 0 C 2 is 0 so 2
times 0 is 0
so C 1 is just going to be equal to a
what I just said a is equal to 0 so the
only solution to this equation right
here the only combination that of the
only linear combination of these three
vectors that result in the zero vector
are when you weight all of them by 0 so
I just showed you that C 1 C 2 and C 3
all have to be 0 and because they're all
0 we know that this is a linearly
linearly independent dependent set of
vectors or that none of these vectors
can be represented as a combination of
the other two
none of these vectors can be represented
as a combination of another two so this
is interesting I have exactly three
vectors that span r3 and they're
linearly independent and linearly
independent in my brain that means it
look I don't have any extra any
redundant vectors anything that could
have just been built with the other
vectors and I have exactly three vectors
and it's spanning r3 so in general and I
haven't proven this to you but I could
is that if you have exactly three
vectors and they do span r3 they have to
be linearly independent if they weren't
linearly independent then one of these
would be redundant then you know you
know let's say that that guy was a
redundant one I was picked the third one
but let's say this guy would be
redundant which means that the span of
this would be equal to the span of these
two right because if this guy is
redundant he could just be he could be
part of the span of these two guys and
the span of two vectors could never span
r3 or the other way you could go if you
have three linear independent three vet
three tuples and they're all independent
then you can also say that that spans r3
but I haven't proven that to you but
hopefully you get the sense that like
each of these is contributing new
directionality right one is you know
going like that they might they're not
completely orthogonal to each other but
they're giving us enough directionality
that you can kind of add a new dimension
to what's going on so hopefully that
helped you a bit and I'll see in the
next video